J'appuie sur ce bouton et ça tire
automatiquement nous faisons quelque chose comme ça
un morceau de celui qui pourrait être avec lui, pour ainsi dire
portez-le dans vos mains plus puissant que
fusil d'assaut kalachnikov
tartes
attaché
le soir, nous avons rencontré notre
par notre personnel si l'oiseau a commencé
commencé à parler comment pouvons-nous aider l'armée quoi
en général pour aller plus loin, il s'est avéré que nous avons
le service emploie des personnes qui
il s'avère qu'il comprend dans les armes ce qui est
par exemple, Alexander, il travaille pour nous
au service et il a dit qu'il y avait des dessins
qui selon lequel vous pouvez
modifier des armes automatiques
pris d'un véhicule blindé de transport de troupes ou dans une arme de poing
avec un entraînement automatique, c'est-à-dire ici
un tel plan c'est ce que nous faisons
refaites la nuit
pour que vous puissiez tirer avec vos mains, c'est-à-dire
voici le chantier
il est clair que tout cela est fait par soi-même, mais elle
les travailleurs, c'est-à-dire que tout fonctionne descend tout
moyennant des frais, c'est une course de falaise jusqu'à ce que nous la terminions
même principe tout de même dans
principe
était automatiquement
de sorte que le véhicule blindé de transport de troupes trophée tué était dedans
trop de munitions
il y avait aussi une telle mitrailleuse à chevalet
domaines sont venus juste doom bouillie peut-elle
vous semblez être dans cette zone fortifiée de yak et pour moi
Je voulais complètement c des sourcils désolé coton
et sceller le pouvoir sur le territoire
[musique]
Ici